basement biden getting the softball town
hall of a lifetime last night
cnn getting ripped for going easy on the
former vp
which stands in stark contrast to how
president trump was treated earlier this
week during his own town hall
with abc take a look if you were
president could you see a scenario where
you downplayed
critical information so as not to cause
panic if you believe it's the
president's responsibility to protect
america
why would you downplay a pandemic how
will you handle russia's involvement
with trump
how will we know the many ways he has
compromised the united states
how do you stop police killing blacks at
three times the
rate of killing whites what is your plan
to build a bridge
with voters from the opposing party why
did you throw vulnerable people like me
under the bus wow
when you look at the montage when they
cut it like that dana it's a pretty
stark contrast as i said
yeah so you know if i were a
presidential candidate i'm looking down
here because i've got a
thing i want to read you because i think
it's going to make everyone laugh
i would rather be trump than biden in
this scenario because
the debate is 10 days away and you have
to practice like you play
and president trump takes tough
questions all the time
he bats him around sometimes he answers
fantastically other times it's like oh
my gosh what is he saying but he is used
to really tough questions joe biden's
not and remember
one of the things about joe biden is he
does have a temper
so if president trump can provoke that
temper that will come off pretty badly
i did want to point this out um the fact
checker over at cnn
said this last night about joe biden
biden makes
some false and misleading claims but his
assertions of fact
have been largely factual
so just basically letting him off the
hook completely
largely factual uh greg what did you
think about last night
well i didn't watch it uh i was my
sister's birthday
so we went out to dinner uh went
downtown to a friend of mine's
restaurant uh called bistro leo
nice i had um i had uh two chicken
dishes
and uh we had some lovely wine nice so i
have basically i'm playing catch up
and what i did do was i went to the
cnn's website and you know
how soft cnn was on biden
when they can't deny it on their website
alice stewart
admits joe got away with stuff at the
town hall
that he wouldn't have gotten away with
at a debate in the sense that no one
held his feet to the fire because you
need a pretty big fire to do that
uh and it made me think about also not
just about how they treated trump but
also i always go back to that insidious
town hall meeting
uh on gun violence where they propped up
that idiot sheriff
remember they made the idiot sheriff
seem like a hero and they just just
went after her and basically put did a
witch trial on dana lash
it's just like they don't hide they
don't hide their biases very well
unlike me yes you're the best at hiding
your bias
the coward from broward i remember that
time all right emily take a look at some
footage here
you know they made this big announcement
at the top that they were going to be
socially distant
and six feet but when they thought they
were going to commercial break
they got a little up close and personal
anderson and joe
when we come back we'll have more uh
more questions from our audience from
former vice president joe biden thanks
oh i mean do we care about that or is
that something that you know everybody
does
well everybody probably does it but i
think what this indicates
is the fact that joe probably forgot
that he had to socially distant
we keep talking about this being a
softball town hall it was
wiffle ball you guys with literally
friends and family
and all of his comments were just
accepted and i actually want to focus on
one that i found the most galling for
maybe a different reason than most
it was the ivy league comment that he
made about president trump we know it
was false of course many presidents have
had
have been presidents without having that
ivy league degree but the point to me
is that it was an elitist privileged
comment and it represents
to me the joe biden that is in reality
what everyone continues to ignore of his
party and it is
exactly what the progressives which are
his handlers
are seeking to dismantle with their
movement which is the old white
privileged male
who furthers the notion that to succeed
in this country or have value in this
country
you had to have participated in and
subscribe to
this elitist structure that already
exists i found it pretty telling
and like everything else it went
unchecked yeah
juan one of the things i noticed with
joe and it's not just in this town hall
he has trouble answering these questions
a lot
his weakest part is when he talks about
climate and energy
fracking and the green new deal he seems
very unsure of himself
and is constantly changing his positions
with regards to those issues because of
his crazy left-wing base
do you see that as a problem going
forward for him because he's having some
difficulty there
i i i'm interested i'll listen uh jesse
but i
i haven't seen that i don't see it i
mean what i saw
well first of all obviously trump didn't
have to do the abc town hall with
undecided voters you know asking
questions he chose to do it he
he walked in there and i think he's a
big boy he knows what's going on
the big difference in these town halls
to me was not the questions because
obviously
at the abc hall and also uh with joe
biden
many of the questions came from the
audience it wasn't the
journalists that you guys like to say
are so biased and i think the big
difference here is
empathy it's the two men joe biden
clearly has
empathy and donald trump clearly doesn't
have empathy
and a lot of voters vote on feelings
even before they get to climate change
and policy
and what they saw was a demonstration of
someone who
you know when he's asked about you know
pre-existing conditions
doesn't have an answer someone start
starts talking to him about someone
dying of cancer he goes off on covet
uh you know joe biden gets interrupted
by a republican
a republican who says joe i'm not
finished and biden says oh i'm sorry go
right ahead and finish
the i mean i think that's a big show
about who they are as human beings and i
think that was the message
and it was not a good message for for
president trump
well i've got to say when it's these
kind of criticisms that
are untethered to it's it's great to say
you know this person doesn't have any
empathy
well maybe you should provide some
actual facts to back that up
the guy is is sending tons and tons of
money to people who are suffering
he's made an incredible economy before
covid you could go
he's he's ushering in these peace deals
but you you have this
incredible evidence that he lacks
empathy but you never tell us
what are the actions that are coming
from that lack of empathy when his
actions are
exactly the opposite of that maybe we
shouldn't
happen if this is the kind of uh
achievements that you're getting from
having no empathy we should all
not have empathy juan do you want to
give an example really well i think that
what we look
yeah i think what happened in the you
know we learned with the woodward book
that he wasn't straight with the
american people and put our health
our families at risk that's lack of
empathy that's not
that no it's not that's a misdiagnosis
on your part all right some people would
say empathy is donald trump's greatest
quality
he would say that some people being
donald trump